then we are right now joined by magnus
carlsen after the magnus where it
doesn't seem you've been in too much
trouble or did you feel a little
threatened in that last game
oh not in the last game but i think i
thought i was lost in uh
in the second okay well i mean
overall i think uh
i had a complete off day today i have to
say that he
also played well without
uh without a lot of mistakes but it
probably
didn't push as much as he could but i
was just completely
uh completely just way way off
today uh and i think
uh i think this is the first time maybe
that i've made
four draws in in a day probably yeah
yeah uh it's kind of it's kind of
amazing if it hasn't happened but i
don't think it has
um anyway i mean i'm thrilled with the
the results considering the
shape i was in today uh i mean i feel
like the only game that i
played kind of decently was the uh was
the first one
um but there there was just nothing and
he defended well to um
to make a draw and apart from that i was
under
some pressure and yeah just happy to
escape
and um and have an equal square
to look forward to tomorrow yeah well it
was a super long day yesterday and also
a very exciting day with the you know
finding out who was the winner of the
candidate so is it a little bit typical
to come the day after that a little bit
low on energy
no i think it's fine it shouldn't
shouldn't be a problem
all right well we do know uh you are a
big favorite if if it's going to go to
tie breaks
magnus so do you feel the situation is
quite good for you before
the second match uh we'll see
we'll see about that i'll certainly uh
certainly do my best to
uh to grab a win tomorrow but he's uh
he's very
very solid and it's it's hard to make uh
it's hard to make headway but
yeah again uh i feel like i
kind of dodged one today so in that
sense i should be
should be optimistic magnus you
mentioned
he's really solid and uh i mean what was
your approach going into today will that
be
altered in any way before tomorrow
um no i don't think so particularly
it's hard to find lines where you can
really go for the throat against him so
i think my approach was okay especially
in the
in the second white game uh trying to
get a small advantage
i just played really really poorly after
after the opening because i think i was
was slightly better and then after after
a few minutes i was
slightly worse so i think it's it's more
about it's more about that but
yeah in general as i said he's hard to
beat
so finally mine is feeling a little off
today what will you do for
the rest of the day and tomorrow before
the games
um i don't know
we'll see uh i mean i even
i went for for a long walk today uh in
order to
feel as fresh as possible because i felt
kind of shitty when i
woke up and then it didn't didn't get
any better
so it's hard to say but
we'll see all right new day new
possibilities thanks for joining magnus
sure thank you